bonjour bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
numéro de ses cachets mission un peu
spécial vous pouvez le remarquer puisque
olivier delamarche n'est pas en plateau
avec moi olivier est avec nous en direct
par skype olivier bonjour est-ce que
vous m'entendez bien c'est skype du coup
confinement oblige que vous allez nous
livrer vos analyses sur les dernières
évolutions liées à la pandémie du coc
vide 19 on va évidemment revenir sur
tout ce qu'il s'est passé ces derniers
jours
et puis dans la deuxième partie de
l'émission on abordera l'impact concret
de cette crise pour les français sur
leur emploi et sur leurs économies
on commence avec un coup d'oeil sur les
marchés financiers la chute se poursuit
à l'ouverture ce lundi 30 mars à la
bourse de paris qui ouvrait donc à -2
60% ça c'est finalement équilibré dans
la journée pour finir à la hausse mais
c'est donc les montagnes russes en ce
moment sur les marchés financiers des
marchés fragilisés depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire olivier faut-il les
fermes et voir les nationaliser pour
éviter un krach boursier irréparables
alors non il faut pas fermer les les
bourses pour la bonne et simple raison
que si vous fermez les bourses nous
empêcher les gens de vendre et donc de
sortir et donc de vous les condamnez à
une poursuite de la baisse puisque quand
vous rouvrirez les marchés il est très
probable que les marchés s'ajusteront à
la récession qui va y avoir la récession
qui est en cours faut bien se dire que
je l' ai déjà dit plusieurs fois mais
une récession normale
c'est quelque chose qui coûte entre 30
et 40 % sur 1 sur un marché par rapport
à ses à ses niveaux d'avant le sait plus
haut qu'on a touché il ya quelques il ya
quelques semaines seulement et
et là vous avez constaté qu'à peu près
tous les marchés dans le monde avait
baissé entre 30 et 40% très proche de
40% 38 pour les états unis
pareil pour chez nous et donc vous avez
donc mis le prix d'une récession normale
maintenant vous n'êtes pas dans une
récession normale vous êtes dans une
récession hors norme
vous avez vu que récemment les les
dernières indications sur les les
indemnités chômage qui avait été demandé
aux états unis ayant théâtrale
évidemment de la situation aux états
unis
presque 2 4 millions c'est quelque chose
qui n'est qui est du jamais vu vous
aviez les pires prévisions qui faisaient
état d'un million et demi de personnes
qui allaient s'inscrire donc vous en
avez plus du double et ce qui veut dire
que ce qui veut dire qu'on va être dans
une récession monumental vous avez
certaines banques qui prévoit une
récession de jusqu'à 24% sur le premier
trimestre donc pensez bien qu'on ait
quelques dents quelque chose de hors
norme
quelque chose de hors norme ça peut
valoir probablement 60 65 % sur un
marché aurait pensé de la mf l'autorité
des marchés financiers qui a interdit la
vente à découvert sur 92 titre à la
bourse de paris
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de cette
initiative écoutez ça serait bien que la
mmf apprennent ce que c'est qu'un marché
financier ça serait utile visiblement
elle ne le sait pas ce qu'elle a fait
aurélien d'abord pas parce que ils sont
persuadés que évidemment si les titres
baisse 1 c'est débile un vendeur à
découvert qui font qu'ils font les
baisses c'est idiot c'est simplement
aussi des gérants qui peut qui vendent
des titres et qui vendent des titres
qu'ils ont
vous savez des gens qui vendent à
découvert des marchés y en a pas
énormément d'abord parce qu'une première
chose et la deuxième chose ce qu'a fait
la mf ne sert strictement à rien parce
que dans la seconde qui suivait on
pouvait évidemment vendre à découvert
toute la liste qu'ils avaient publié
c'était assez simple en fait il
suffisait de vendre les futurs et
d'acheter toutes les études qui n'était
pas dans la liste et à ce moment là deux
fêtes vous étiez vendeur sur la sur la
lys donc c'est idiot ça ne sert à rien
c'est juste de la com et ça prouve une
bonne chose c'est que les gens qui
travaillent à la mf ne sont pas au
courant de ce que c'est qu'un marchés
financiers alors parmi les réponses qui
ont été apportées par les banques
centrales et les gouvernements
il ya ce chiffre plus de 5000 milliards
de dollars c'est ce qu'ont promis
d'injecter les vingt premières
puissances économiques le g20 elles ont
promis d'injecter dans l'économie à
travers notamment des politiques
fiscales ciblées des mesures économiques
et des plans pour contrer les impacts
sociaux économiques et financiers de la
pandémie olivier est ce que c'est une
réponse qui est à la hauteur de la
gravité de la situation
c'est ce que je vous ai toujours dit
c'est-à-dire que le jour où il y aurait
un problème sur les sur les marchés ce
qui est le cas le jour où il y aura un
problème sur les marchés ça serait
carnet ouvert open bar open bars des
banques centrales c'est ce qu'ont mené
ce à quoi on assiste depuis quelques
quelques semaines où on voit que les
banques centrales ont en gros annoncé
que quel que soit le coût
et elle essaierait de tenir les marchés
donc on est en train si vous voulez de
ce japonisé au niveau des banques
centrales
et pareil pour les annonces économiques
des gouvernements
ces carnets ouvert c'est-à-dire on se
fiche complètement de savoir à combien
ça va coûter cette histoire on s'endette
comme jamais donc ne vous faites aucune
illusion
ça vous reviendra dans la figure au
niveau des impôts je vous ai toujours
dit la dette c'est de l'impôt décalé et
bien vous allez vous en apercevoir
bientôt que ça va être un cauchemar faut
bien se le mettre dans la tête c'est à
dire que vous avez aujourd'hui des pays
à l'arrêt ce qui veut dire que vous avez
des gens qui sont des indépendants qui
sont des pme qui vont être à court de
trésorerie dans les jours qui viennent
donc et je doute que les états quels
qu'ils soient
arrive à combler toutes là toutes les
pertes qu'ils vont être fait au niveau
des ménages au niveau des entreprises au
niveau des pme au niveau des des gens
qui ont des des bouleaux indépendant d'e
et qui vont malheureusement fait
d'ailleurs plus en longueur sur l'impact
sur sur les gens et leur économie
quelques chiffres d'abord sur l'europe
avec les prévisions de récession qui ont
été annoncées qui ont été avancés avec
notamment pour la france
une récession est prévu entre 1,4 et 1,7
pour cent 2 6% ce qui concerne le
royaume-uni et -5% pour l'allemagne
olivier un mot sur ses prévisions déjà
est ce qu'elle vous semble réaliste je
vois pas pourquoi la france aurait une
aussi petite récession que 1,4 pour cent
je ne pense pas que lille y ait un effet
le maire 1 qui suffisent à faire en
sorte qu' on est une toute petite
récession et qu'on soit le seul pays
dans le monde à ne pas être touché par
le corps d'un virus je vous rappelle
quand même que l'économie est arrêté en
france et que ça m'étonnerait que ça ne
se traduise que par une récession de 1,4
alors on part de zéro un faux pas on
était on était sur une une croissance
qui était nulle depuis déjà un petit
moment et là comme par hasard on est là
on est le pays qui s'en sort le mieux
donc que j'ai des gros doutes oui gros
doutes pur sûr c'est sur ces niveaux de
récession je pense que pouvaient déjà
les x 2 et puis vous serez probablement
un tout petit peu plus proche de la
réalité surtout que ça sert à rien s'il
voulait de faire des prévisions
aujourd'hui alors qu'on ne sait même pas
quand est ce qu'on va sortir de cette de
cette histoire de confinement je vous
rappelle et je vous le disais la en
début on avait on avait des banquiers je
crois que c'est goldman sachs qui a fait
une prévision pour le premier trimestre
américain à -24% et vous avez le même
jour jp morgan qui sort une prévision à
-14% pour le q1 ce qui veut dire quoi ce
qui veut dire tout simplement qu'ils
n'en savent rien
et que donc quand vous avez des écarts
comme ça et que vous avez de l'autre
côté la france qui agite un petit moins
1,4 pour cent ça me fait hurler de rire
concernant les réponses à l'échelle
européenne quelles peuvent être ses
réponses et la banque centrale qui a par
exemple demandé aux banques de la zone
euro de ne pas verser de dividendes
jusqu'au 1er octobre 2020 au moins et
dans le même temps on voit que la
réponse européenne est un peu fragile
l'édifice européen risque de perdre sa
raison d'être c'est giuseppe comté qui a
prononcé cette phrase qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette réponse à l'échelle
européenne qui a pas de réponse à
l'échelle européenne je pense que depuis
le début de cette histoire
on voit bien que l'europe est
inexistante donc au contraire c'est à
dire je vous rappelle quand même que
pour l'instant les pays qui aident
l'italie c'est la russie c'est la chine
essaie cuba j'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir cité beaucoup de pays européens
de l'union européenne en tout cas dans
ce que je viens de vous dire donc des
êtres qu'ils sont mis en place désormais
entre la france et l'allemagne notamment
excusez moi depuis le début
madame merkel joue sa sa carte se fiche
complètement de ce que raconte monsieur
macron et et inversement donc
et les italiens c'est pareil il demande
de l'aide depuis le début et la seule
chose qu'on est lui à faire pour
l'instant c'est de les insulter en
disant qu'ils étaient nuls et qu'ils
avaient mal
il avait mal fait il avait mal géré
cette cette histoire de la part de
monsieur macron ça fait doucement rire
et donc voilà excusez moi il n'y a pas
d'europe
c'est bien d'ailleurs un des indes est
une des grandes leçons de ce corps en un
virus c'est que l'europe est si elle a
un jour existé est morte
donc je pense que dès la fin de cette
histoire
certains comptes seront demandées et que
on arrêtera cette cette histoire qui n'a
pas lieu d'être
on a vu l'a récemment que monsieur
macron demandé ça ne m'étonne pas de lui
demander bbb corona bond et vous avez eu
la réponse cinglante des allemands et
des pays bas donc il n'y aura pas de
corans n'abondent ça semble compliqué en
effet pour ce qui concerne les cordes
abandon va marquer une pause
olivier une très courte pause on revient
dans quelques instants pour continuer de
parler de la situation économique est
liée à la pandémie de kobe dix neuf de
retour dans ces caches émission un peu
spéciale puisque vous le voyez olivier
delamarche n'est pas avec moi en plateau
il est avec nous à distance confinement
oblige avant de parler de la situation
économique en france et de l'impact de
cette crise due cori 19 sur les français
un mot d'abord olivier sur les états
unis vous en parliez à quelques instants
pendant la semaine du 15 au 21 mars
dernier un total de 3 3 millions
d'américains ont fait une demande
d'allocations chômage c'est trois
millions de demandeurs de plus par
rapport à la semaine précédente
alors après avoir annoncé vouloir une
reprise de l'activité pour le 12 avril
donald trump table désormais sur des
juin pour relancer la machine est ce que
c'est possible selon vous olivier tout
est possible vous savez il ya bientôt
des élections aux états unis donc même
les miracles deviennent possibles
non sérieusement on va voir on va avoir
une je vous dis une va cession hors
norme
toutes les prévisions alors ça c'est
c'est assez c'est assez générale en ce
moment vous avez toutes les tous les
bureaux de l'analyse qui vous mr est une
sortie de récession qui prévoit une
sortie de récession
comme d'habitude c'est à dire ce qu'on
appelle la sortie enlever c'est à dire
le une sortie qui serait à une vitesse
équivalente de de l'entrée en récession
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dû notamment lors
des dernières crises des crises
précédentes
oui mais c'est ça qui est amusant c'est
que si vous voulez on on réagit toujours
par rapport à ce qu'on connaît donc par
rapport à un historique mais
malheureusement c'est ce que je vous ai
dit l'historique ne sert strictement à
rien dans ce cas là puisque on en a pas
on a rien qui ressemble à ce que ce qui
est en train de se passer
à aucun moment dans l'histoire récente
et même si vous allez un tout petit peu
plus loin que l'histoire récente
vous n'avez eu des pays à l'arrêt jamais
même en temps de guerre donc des pays à
l'arrêt si vous voulez ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir des pertes des pertes
mais mais structurel pas simplement un
espèce de déplacement de dépenses là
tout le monde pense que quand le le
confinement va s'arrêter tout le monde
va sortir et tout le monde a dépensé 4
fois plus que ce que
que ce qu'il n'a pas dépensé pendant
pendant les semaines de confinement sais
c'est mal connaître les choses c'est que
vous êtes aujourd'hui avec des gens qui
ont ce qu'on consomme et leur trésorerie
n'ont plus aucune entrée vont commencer
à taper dans leur épargne
et quand ils vont sortir du confinement
si vous voulez ils n'ont pas d'argent à
les dépenser et donc n'espérez pas
qu'ils aient une reprise en v
vous allez avoir quelque chose qui va
plus ressembler à un l
si vous voulez donc une reprise qui va
être probablement très progressive et
très faible on va voir olivier sur ces
images des graphiques justement sur
cette fameuse courbe en v dont vous
parliez c'était le cas notamment en 1973
premier choc pétrolier ou en 2008 lors
de la dernière grosse crise financière
et c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois
l'économie est repartie assez rapidement
finalement après la crise financière est
ce que cette fois vous qu'est ce qui
vous fait dire en fait que cette fois on
sera dans un scénario qui sera très
différent il ya aucune aucun motif
d'espoir du fait que l'économie puisse
repartir mais c'est pas elle sait pas
qui a aucun motif d'espoir le l'économie
repartira si vous voulez mais elle
repartira pas du tout sur les mêmes
rythmes qu'on a connu on avait là pour
le coup on avait des crises qui jusqu'à
même jusqu'à celle de 2008 étaient des
crises qui était décrit ce normal s'il
voulait là vous n'êtes plus du tout dans
le même dans le même modèle si vous
voulez vous êtes vous n'avez pas refait
de grave n'avait pas refait départ on a
quelque chose qui a été soufflée vous
avez une bulle boursière qui a été
soufflé mais les entreprises n'ont pas
fait autant gras que dans l'est dans les
périodes précédentes
et vous êtes sur des taux de chômage
dans beaucoup de pays qui sont encore
très très élevée avec une précarisation
du travail et c'est pas bon
on peut en parler pendant pendant
pendant des heures même aux états unis
où
on se vantait d'avoir un taux de plein
emploi ce qui était largement faux on
était sur des sur des niveaux qui
étaient beaucoup plus haut et donc là
dessus arrive une crise est une crise
comme on en a jamais vu qui bloquent
complètement les pays qui bloquent la
production des bébés pays donc un des
pays qui sont à l'arrêt justement lyon
va parler de ces pays à la raison en
parlant de la situation de la france
quelques chiffres qui nous ont été
donnés donc notamment par l'insee la
perte d'activité économique en france
est estimé selon l'insee à 35% en raison
notamment donc des mesures de
confinement qui sont en place dans le
pays alors les secteurs de l'industrie
de la construction sont particulièrement
touchés on voit notamment le secteur de
la construction dont l'hypothèse de
perte d'activité par rapport à la
normale est estimé à -1 89% et services
marchands également qu'ils connaîtraient
une feinte fort recul en moins 36% et
parallèlement à ces baisses d'activité
il ya la consommation qui est en berne
c'est évidemment un des autres impacts
du confinement sur l'économie avec
notamment là encore le secteur de la
construction qui connaîtrait une perte
d'activité d'au moins 90% les services
marchands également là encore très
fortement impactée plus généralement
l'insee estime qu'un mois de confinement
aura pour conséquence une perte de 3
points de pib sur l'année olivier on le
voit donc les moyens mis en place pour
contrer la pandémie coûte et continuez
et vous continuez de coûter très cher à
la france il va bien pourtant falloir
payer l'addition alors cette question
qui va payer cette addition c'est nous
et tu te fais dire c'est les scellés les
français passent et les français en
france et les italiens en italie c'est
les américains aux états unis c'est nous
qui allons les payer
le nageur a diminué par exemple
concrètement qu'est ce qu'il va pouvoir
qui va impacter minuee vous avez vous
avez les gens qui courent pour sentir et
vont taper dans leur épargne
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé quand
même depuis presque deux ans maintenant
en france c'est à dire les gilet jaune
les gilet jaune c'était quoi c'était des
gens qui le le 10 du mois était à
découvert d'accord est ce que vous
pensez que la situation actuelle va
arranger les choses n'ont forcément ces
gens là m'ont plus d'entrées donc ils
vont consommer le maigre cash qu'ils
avaient sur sur leurs portefeuilles
seront très probablement obligé de taper
dans leur épargne quand ils en ont une
et donc c'est pour ça que je vous dis
qu'après ça va pas repartir comme ça et
regarder les chiffres que vous avez
montré là à l'instant de l'insee qui
vous dit que c'est 3 % de perte de pib
par mois de confinement donc comme on va
avoir un minimum de deux mois de
confinement points de pib effectivement
ça fera ça fera 6 points de pib donc
est-ce que c'est cohérent par rapport
aux estimations que vous m'avez donné en
début de démission où on avait une une
récession de 1,4 pour cent sur l'année
en france non bien sûr que non donc
c'est pour ça que je vous dis on va
avoir quelque chose qui va fortement
impacter les gens et même s'il veut
l'argent sur leur compte les épargnants
est ce qu ils peuvent être impactés
certains se rappellent du scénario
chypriote dans lequel
les banques avaient pu puiser dans les
épargnes alors c'était au delà de cent
mille euros ça concernait
essentiellement des entreprises voilà
mais est ce qu'on peut imaginer que les
épargnants puisse être inquiétés et ont
des raisons d'être inquiets à cause de
cette crise ils ont des raisons d'être
inquiet pourquoi parce que c'est ce que
je vous dise dans très vite que ce soit
des pme que ce soit des indépendants que
ce soit des ménages très vite ils vont
être obligés aujourd'hui de taper dans
leur est pas ça veut dire que ils vont
demander des rachats partiels de leurs
de la ration ans vie qu'ils vont sortir
de certains produits bancaires pour
simplement pour vivre pour avoir du cash
et c'est là que ça risque de mal évolué
dans les banques
c'est à dire vous pouvez très bien avoir
un contrôle des capitaux qui est mis en
place
s'il ya trop d'argent qui sort des
banques
on peut aussi vous bloquez et vous
ressortir la loi sapin 2 qui permet de
d'empêcher les rachats d'assurance-vie
essayer aujourd'hui franchement essayer
aujourd'hui de sortir de l'argent d'une
d'une banque
vous allez voir que on va vous mettre
des bâtons dans les roues pour essayer
en ce qui concerne les retraites
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une
pénurie de cash notamment parce qu'on
voit qu'il ya beaucoup de gens il
semblerait que beaucoup de gens
soit tenté de retirer leur argent des
banques est-ce que vous pensez que
beaucoup de gens compte il ya eu le
confinement est ce que vous pensez que
beaucoup de gens avaient fait une
provision de bié chez eux n'ont donc ça
veut dire que très vite ils vont être à
cours de cash
donc quand ali vont vouloir aller en
chercher lits seront très probablement
bloqués donc oui bien sûr que vous avez
aujourd'hui un risque majeur que où vous
bloque dans les banques et qu'on ne vous
rendent pas votre votre cash c'est une
évidence
donc je pense que toutes les banques
aujourd'hui sont dans une situation où l
on pas très envie que ça arrive mais ça
m'étonnerait pas moi
si le confinement se prolonge qui a
l'air d'être quand même le cas en je
pense pas qu'on en sorte avant moi mais
si le confinement se prolonger bien vous
allez avoir forcément des demandes de
récupérer du cash parce que les gens
peuvent pas vivre donc à nous de finir
origines et sur l'après crise du coc
vide 19 on est évidemment encore en
plein dans cette crise mais on peut se
projeter c'est en tout cas ce qu'a fait
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
johann site
il faut un nouveau capitalisme qui
soient plus respectueux des personnes
qui soient plus soucieux de lutter
contre les inégalités qui soient plus
respectueux de l'environnement
s'il peut sortir quelque chose de bon de
cette crise c'est une accélération de
cette prise de conscience
olivier en quelques mots et ce qu'on
doit changer notre modèle économique à
la sortie de cette crise oui mais il
faudra changer les hommes
pour changer le modèle si vous voulez on
peut pas changer le modèle avec des
hommes qui nous ont mis dedans donc
monsieur le maire en fait partie je
pense pas que l'on puisse faire
du neuf avec du vieux et
et surtout imaginer un nouveau modèle
avec des gens qui depuis des années sont
partisans de l'ancien modèle à tout prix
et qui nous ont amenés dans la situation
actuelle
merci beaucoup olivier c'est déjà la fin
de cette émission merci à tous de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez réagir à cette
émission dans la section commentaires de
ses vidéos notamment sur facebook et sur
youtube pouvez également nous poser des
questions on essaiera d'y répondre dans
nos prochaines éditions et puis je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou revoir
cette émission sur le site rtl france
point tv tradition oblige olivier même
si vous êtes loin de nous le mot de la
fin est pour dia écouter le corps n'a
virus nous a mis dans une situation très
compliquée j'espère en effet au moins
qui nous servira de leçon et que l'on
pourra déboucher sur autre chose après